[Music]
you are an embrace of fact that set and
Blair ended up together
you guys ever laugh about that
occasionally yeah maybe occasionally
once again we have a second Blair day
it's exciting for laughs it's good for a
laugh Leighton Meester and Adam Brody
finally acknowledging their Gossip Girl
and OC Teenage Dream marriage et was
exclusively with a pair for their first
joint interview they were serving
lunches to children on Tuesday in Los
Angeles with feeding America the
nation's largest hunger relief
organization Tiffani Thiessen and
daughter Harper also joined this really
awesome organization that brings
awareness and volunteer opportunities
for people to talk about an issue that's
super important and I think very little
known which is hunger that is a huge
problem in America and even in Los
Angeles where we live and also just
getting to hang with the kids was really
fun I feel like they're excited but you
guys look just as excited it's weird but
I actually get a little nervous that
they're gonna not like me you know I
don't care I'm eating lunch who's this
jerk you know and so the fact that they
you know engage and seem to have a good
time is uh it's wonderful I wasn't I
wasn't prepared and it's really nice to
get to see them one-on-one and like
actually have contact with them and see
the difference that you know you're
hopefully making and to be able to play
and like have a good time and there's so
much fun and they're so smart and cool
and an awesome it's just nice to forge a
bit of a connection and it's just good
motivation Tiffany was here with her
daughter Harper what are you guys hoping
to instill and your daughter are Lois
she grows up about giving back and how
important it is well she's too little to
come here today she would be like I
don't get it but I think it's a really I
mean you know even for us like this is
sort of like something that we're even
learning about and I think that it's
really important to show your children
that there are different sides to
everything I mean this is a summer
hunger
campaign for the awareness of like all
the kids in America that they don't have
food during the summer so I think you
know you sort of take that for granted
and I think so just instill in your
children or to teach your children and
to also remember yourself that you you
know you're super lucky and like also to
reach out and to help and just to
remember that I'm trying to instill in
myself still let alone pass it on
[Music]
you